[Música]
[Aplausos]
en este momento estamos acá en placita
área
santiago en chile
pero en pocos minutos podemos estar
viviendo la revolución francesa ustedes
seguramente se deberá estar preguntando
cómo puede pasar esto y la respuesta es
muy sencilla con algo tan simple
como un libro
a través de ellos podemos crear
realidades distintas a las nuestras
mezcladas con nuestra experiencia y la
del escritor
pero lamentablemente para muchos jóvenes
la lectura es solo una actividad que nos
mandó antes del colegio y eso se ve
reflejado directamente en resultados de
pruebas estandarizadas como son el simce
y las deseo en donde según la ocde chile
es uno de los países con más bajos
índices de comprensión lectora
muchas veces se dice que no leemos por
cuerpo del iva en donde el precio de
libro es muy caro pero eso es
completamente falso porque hay estudios
que demuestran que el momento el lector
no va de la mano en sí por el precio del
libro sino más bien con políticas
gubernamentales y la lectura es
fundamental para mejorar el capital
cultural de nosotros los jóvenes el cual
hace referencia a la cantidad de cultura
adquirida y no solo los museos son
cultura los libros también
cada vez que leemos nuestra mente se
enfrente a distintas realidades
opiniones y visiones por ejemplo cuando
yo le iba con ley master ya que
seguramente muchos de ustedes deben
haber lillo
pude sentir lo querido un adolescente
con cáncer me enamoré de algún software
pero después terminé llorando cuando
muere perdón celis spoiler arias lo
siento no era mi intención a través de
los libros podemos mejorar nuestras
ideas y esta manera también comprender
el mundo a través de ellos también
aprendemos y hacía más difícil que
seamos manipulados
cuando yo leí mi primer libro en
verdadero leyeron después viene la
sabrosita pero no me acuerdo muy bien
les voy a hablar de bueno que sí
recuerdo que me lo regaló mi tío para
navidad que fue el que yo benítez boiero
tapa dura con olor a libro nuevo
maravilloso en donde fue el primer libro
que yo me sentí la protagonista porque
ella contaba lo que vivía diariamente
era un día de vida así de simple pero
fue con ese libro en donde persecución
perdón la palabra cambió completamente
porque me di cuenta que yo como lectora
podía interpretar lo que el escritor
había hecho para mí y antes de continuar
con este relato quiero que ustedes se
involucren acá también por favor
levanten la mano
cuánta gente le por gusto
tenemos una sala muy lectora maravilloso
estaba súper bacán súper simple y hacer
el ejercicio
yo les voy a pensar a contar una
historia a continuación y necesito que
la haríamos como un libro que lo viva
este relato como si fuera suyo
en 2015 se ve también con ello como les
comentaban acá me cambié de colegio y me
di cuenta que muchas de mis compañeras
también leía y que la biblioteca mi
establecimiento no estaba en los libros
que yo como adolescente que vienen pero
en ese entonces leen gore no le presta
atención pero no fue hasta el 2016 en
enero en donde se me mete en la cabeza
la idea de ser presidente del curso y me
pongo a pensar en alguna iniciativa para
que mis compañeros votaron por mí y me
acuerdo esto que ya se compartía en los
libros en la sala pero no todas
conocíamos los títulos que tenía la otra
entonces lo que había que hacer era
generar un sistema que formalizará todo
esto y eso aquí con se me ocurre el día
de intercambio de libros y esta idea se
me ocurre en el mejor lugar de todos se
me ocurre en donde nosotros como humanos
podemos estar un rato solos pensar
se me ocurre en el baño
lo que nosotros hacemos es crear una
comunidad de interacción lectora en
donde los estudiantes se comparten
aquellos libros que desean leer hacemos
un tráfico de libros ocupamos economía
colaborativa porque el libro suscrita
infinitas veces y lo más probable que no
me hayan entendido perico de lo que
acabo de decir acá entonces les voy a
dar un ejemplo que con sólo seis pasos
el libro va a ser tuyo juan quiere leer
un libro
fue ingresa al catálogo está de manera
online el tercer paso es que juan le
pide libro al encargado de su curso
el encargado del curso le consigue el
libro con el dueño de éste y
posteriormente cuarto lee el libro y
cuando juan termina de leerlo
el libro se vuelve al dueño así es fácil
todo leemos todos somos felices pero
juan ya no va a ser el lector solo ya no
va a ser el lector el señor y el
apartado de la sala ya no más cuando
empezará a formar parte de una comunidad
de interacción lectora en donde va a
tener beneficios exclusivos como es el
caso de los lectores modelos los cuales
nos cuentan sus experiencias como
lectores es aquí en donde nos dimos
cuenta estaríamos dando un paso más allá
de nuestra misión literaria no sólo
estábamos escuchando a personas sobre
libros estábamos aprendiendo de
experiencias distintas a las nuestras
con nuestra humilde imitación abrimos
nuestra escuela para que personas con
roles sociales nos enseñaran y nos
dejaron un mensaje claro
no estamos solos y entre más jóvenes
comiencen nuestro hábito lector más
probabilidades hay que perder durante
toda nuestra vida quizá aquí es donde
esta actividad se prefiera como otro
aprendizaje de calidad aprendemos de la
experiencia del otro y contamos con la
motivación de otros que quiere
involucrarse en nuestro proceso
educativo que se vuelve más estable y
significativo en el tiempo
que habíamos va un paso más allá
nuestras compañeras ya estaban leyendo
que nos estábamos ayudando entre
nosotras ya estábamos cubriendo mundos
distintos a los nuestros a través de los
libros
por este simple mecanismo hace unas
semanas podíamos ver placer y la
responsabilidad de representar a chileno
el encuentro internacional en donde nos
reunimos con más de 16 jóvenes no más de
16 equipos personas que tenían proyectos
como los nuestros y es así como poco a
poco nos hemos ido convirtiendo en un
movimiento que fomenta la lectura
pero hubo algo que fue clave en todo
este proceso que fue la actitud en donde
si es necesario tener los conocimientos
son super importante las habilidades
pero la actitud de la que multiplica
cuántas veces nos hemos quejado de las
cosas que pasan a nuestro alrededor yo
muchas veces me quejé de la biblioteca
de mi colegio pero en un momento me di
cuenta que mi proyecto solucionada está
esta problemática y no tan solo en mi
colegio sino en muchos otros colegios
municipales de chile- nosotros y nos
vamos en el mundo la lectura ustedes
también pueden orar tal como lo hice
cervantes en el ingenioso hidalgo don
quijote de la mancha' en donde hay un
centenar de palabras al idioma español
y armen un buen equipo de trabajo eso es
súper importante un equipo de trabajo en
donde busquen personas que tengan las
mismas actitudes que las suyas que
quieran cumplir los mismos objetivos en
muy equipo nuestro objetivo es que los
jóvenes lean como jóvenes leamos la
lectura es súper importante para
nosotros ya que significa la llave del
conocimiento cada vez que leemos nos
podemos mezclar con otras con otras
personas culturas religiones e incluso
dolores
como reto me lo crítica al principio la
revolución francesa la podemos vivir a
través de los miserables con con ahí
podemos sentir las precariedades que
irían las personas en aquella época como
jóvenes leamos esas limitaciones y que
dejemos de ver el libro como la
actividad que nos mandan desde el
colegio veámoslo como un mundo lleno de
posibilidades muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]